hi my name is anneka Kumar and the
founder CEO from quality digital I coach
a platform that connects small-scale
farmers with investors for the purpose
of booster food production in the
country
I'm proud of the startup in much about
21 months ago and today we've been able
to work with about 7,000 small-scale
farmers across ten states in Nigeria so
what we've done is we've pretty much
simplified how people now get involved
in farming practices so now you can go
on a mobile device or now move an app or
you've gone on websites and decide that
you want to be amazed rice or suya or
cassava farmer and then at that point
you make a decision and then invest your
money through the platform when you just
so we then engage a farm on your behalf
that becomes a partner with you where
then goes to work on the farm and he's
providing you with updates in front of
pictures videos and texts until the
farmer cycle is done in addition to that
you can also visit your farmer that
you've partnered with to find out about
the progress of the fab right here at
the farm so that level of involvement
we're now partnering with real farmers
that are working on farms elsewhere
gives people opportunity to now be
anywhere they are using mobile devices
and now I too have now become a farmer
because I got involved with hard rock
and then at the end of the harvest
season you don't get your body back
another return after habits so you just
be able to go through the full cycle
through your mobile device or or the
website top-quality itself is designed
for the guys that wanna invest but
always go to the farm and so you're not
able to bring it back through a platform
for us to do local fast on the father's
side however the advantage we able to
bring to their base that we be gettin
the imputes they need at low cost so
they get impious seed fertilize a label
they get technical know-how to work
Ferb's and they get back up access for
them to sell their five reviews in all
of these points when it comes to
impedance there's not much around
technology that we do with our regards
when it comes to technical know-how in
other extant the hands of our extension
extension workers what with this we
provide the fathers of the ability
building solutions around providing
focus our ability for them to start
interacting with tech coffee especially
that him physically physically PDA using
the SSD called touch points like that to
reach out to them together to provide
whatever questions they have at this
district caffeine specialist are able to
respond to that or the bucket side we
then provide the farmers with the best
bucket of evil as a result of the
efforts for I headway were able to
source for people that are looking to
buy the commodity or by reading habits
that we're now introducing African
farmers to the technologies we tell them
will help them improve their farm
operations or increase the yield by
provided demonstration farms where we're
able to now find a bastard of farmers so
in the competition 405's
each having a hectare we began two or
three that we can work with in the first
year I will be sure that see how we able
to improve this yield see how were able
to get him market access see how were
able to deploy the EPS with him and see
how much the farmer has speed that in
itself helps to sell and as the
irrespective of how ignorant the father
is he sees four by a do it well it's
enough knowledge for him to do that he
needs to chop all
[Music]